c'est l'une des rares femmes à diriger
une grande société cotée en bourse pour
genève album bonjour david ça va très
bien merci vous installez vous traînez
directrice générale de maisons du monde
alors seules trois femmes aujourd'hui
son patron d'une boîte du cac 40 on va
les donner à ces chez angie chez orange
depuis peu et chez veolia c'est prévu
pour les prochains mois trois sur 40
qu'est ce qu'on se dit on se dit quoi
que le compte n'y est pas en matière de
parité c'est mathématique ou qu' il ya
trois mois et ben n'y avait qu'une seule
femme patronne du cac 40 et donc voilà
que les choses sont peut-être en train
de s'accélérer comment est-ce qu'on voit
la chose verre d'eau à moitié vide ou à
moitié plein alors moi je suis d'un
naturel optimiste donc j'ai plutôt
tendance à avoir ça comme une voie de
progrès et si je prends le sbf 120 lors
de ma nomination en 2018 ont été à peine
8 maintenant on est treize ou quatorze
donc ça aussi je pense que c'est un vrai
progrès bien sûr il reste du chemin à
faire pour une femme accéder au sommet
de la pyramide au sommet de l'entreprise
ça reste un chemin pavé d'embûches il ya
encore un sprint et le plafond de verre
alors les statistiques l'indiquent donc
ce plafond des recettes une réalité
d'après les chiffres moi je n'ai jamais
vécu comme tel je n'ai jamais ressenti
ce plafond de verre et je pense que
c'est lié à deux raisons la première
c'est que je ne me suis jamais senti
moins capable je n'ai jamais eu
l'impression que j'avais moins droit à
un homme et je pense qu'à celles resta
de plein de choses c'est un tempérament
une éducation en environnement et je
pense que du coup il faut que l'on
commence très tôt dans l'éducation dans
la sensibilisation à ces biais cognitif
culturel pour que justement les petites
filles se disent qu'elles sont au moins
autant capable qu'elles ont au moins
droit à donc je pense que ça c'est
toxique aux logiques c'est à dire que
voilà parce que l'art et essai que les
femmes ont toujours du mal à accéder
aujourd'hui à des postes de direction il
ya la loire x1 qui a été votée justement
pour qu'ils souhaitent pas 30 40 % d'ici
d'ici quelques années voilà il ya je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de de croyances
et de limites personnelles que les
femmes s'imposent les freins de frankel
seulement sur lesquels collectivement on
doit travailler le premier frein c'est
le manque de confiance en soi on parle
souvent du syndrome de l'imposteur
de ce complexe en effet des femmes qui
se disent que l n'y arriveront pas
qu'elle ne mérite pas qu'elle ne pouvons
pas faire face donc ça c'est très
important et puis aussi une deuxième
croix en ce parce que je pense que c'en
est véritablement une des femmes qui est
de dire mais si je veux réussir je vais
à sacrifier tout le reste et ça ce n'est
pas possible ma vie ne se définit pas
que par mon travail on doit aussi
traduire cette croyance donc c'est un
conseil qu'on peut donner aux femmes qui
nous regardent qui souhaitent accéder à
des postes avec plus de responsabilités
ces lois là de croire en elle de croire
que c'est possible et de si je crois ma
propre expérience disons que si j'avais
eu cette conviction que pour accéder à d
autres responsabilités je devais
sacrifier ou une grande partie a minima
de ma vie personnelle et familiale j'y
serais jamais allé j'aurais tout
simplement renoncé pas parce que le
sacrifice est trop dur mais simplement
parce que pour moi il n'avait pas de
sens gym moi c'était important d'avoir
cet équilibre et j'ai en plus je pense
honnêtement que le fait d'avoir cet
équilibre aussi avec ma vie personnelle
familiale fait deux mois la dirigeante
que je suis donc ça ça va deux paires
donc il faut absolument en effet combat
ses croyances et une femme qui a dit un
truc intéressant qui quand on légifère
pas on trouve des excuses et quand on
légifère on trouve des femmes savaient
qui a dit ça c'est christine lagarde
président de la bce elle a raison ça
rejoint ce qu'on disait avant sur le
fait de faire des quotas encore une fois
pour les femmes
à des postes de direction à des postes à
responsabilité et quotas c'est toujours
un sujet sensible parce que les femmes
peuvent aussi se dire que du coup elle y
arrive parce que le quota est une fois
de plus parce qu'elles ne sont pas
capables donc c'est important à nouveau
travailler sur ces billets maintenant
les quotas aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est une nécessité pourquoi parce que
je pense que les femmes comme on le
disait ont besoin de penser que c'est
possible et pour ça elles ont besoin
d'avoir plein de modèles de réussite
différents avec des styles différents
avec les exigences différentes avec des
critères différentes d'avoir deux trois
quatre cinq femmes qui sont des wonder
woman qui ont d autres responsabilités
qui font si la fête de l'école week-end
et qui se lève à 5 heures pour faire du
yoga c'est magnifique c'est génial mais
ça ça ne parle pas à toutes les femmes
et donc ses quotas ça permet aussi
justement d'avoir bain des nombre
important de femmes qui incarnent cette
diversité et qui permettent à toutes ces
femmes de se projeter de se reconnaître
et qui disent bon bah là on other woman
c'est peut-être pas pour moi mais ça
c'est là peut-être que oui en fait quoi
de femmes managers pour le coucher chez
maisons du monde est ce que cette parité
hommes-femmes sur les postes encore ils
font à responsabilité pasta direction et
déjà respectée avant que la loi vous y
contraignent d'ici quelques années alors
oui parce qu on est à 50 % au niveau du
heynckes on est à 50 % au niveau du
conseil d'administration mais à 50% au
niveau du top son et au delà même 70% de
nos promotions internes sont décernés à
des femmes donc on est en effet une
entreprise très féminisée mais on a eu
la chance d'être nommé top 5 du sbf 120
pour la féminisation des instances
dirigeantes c'est à dire que à profiler
à compétences égales vous choisirez une
femme plutôt qu'un homme sur un toast à
recruter alors pas du tout nous on est
question sauce pas comme ça oui non
vraiment pas ça peut arriver je veux
dire cette configuration qui arrive ça
peut alors nous on veuille vraiment à la
mixité à la diversité donc c'est très
important d'aller chercher cet équilibre
d'ailleurs on parle de l'égalité
hommes-femmes on pourrait parler aussi
de mixité sociale enfin on s'engage
aujourd'hui maison du monde dans
l'égalité des chances de façon plus
importante que par le passé avec
notamment ce combat égalité homme femme
mais aussi notamment l'égalité des
chances et l'accès pour les jeunes
notamment issus des milieux défavorisés
à l'emploi ya beaucoup d'idées
préconçues sur sur la façon de diriger
d'un homme ou d'une femme comme quoi les
femmes sera un peu plus prudente les
hommes peut prendre plus de risques
c'est quoi ces clichés tout ça ou est-ce
que voilà ça dépend finalement du
tempérament de la personnalité du
dirigeant dépendamment de son sexe
alors oui la grande question du
leadership féminin ou du leadership
masculin je pense que en effet c'est pas
une question de genre il ya plein de
leadership tout comme il ya des
leaderships de petites entreprises qui
sont très différents mais leadership des
grandes entreprises quand on fonde une
start up c'est pas les mêmes compétences
dont on a besoin que quand on doit
restructurer une entreprise très
importante donc je pense qu'en effet on
peut pas prendre de raccourcis je pense
que le premier très moi que je trouve
chez les femmes c'est cette prise de
recul ce sens de la perspective parce
que justement comme je le disais tout à
l'heure le travail étant des aspects de
nos vies mais pour beaucoup d'entre nous
nous sommes maman pour ma part j'ai
trois enfants 10 en six ans quatre ans
ça prend plein espace dans ma vie avec
ma famille et puis j'ai d'autres vies
par ailleurs et donc le fait d'avoir cet
équilibre d'abord un nous donne plus
naturellement ce sens du recul et donc
jamais de donner des perspectives aux
choses et nous rend aussi très concrète
très dans l'action tr dans l'efficacité
passe quand on donne et on veut que ce
soit efficace pour justement avoir du
temps pour toutes ces vies
donc ça c'est le premier truc c'est
vraiment ce côté très concret très
pragmatique avec cette prise de recul
après on prête beaucoup aussi aux femmes
le management par l'empathie par l'
écoute je pense que les coudes ce n'est
pas l'apanage des femmes c'est vrai que
dans les codes historique de leadership
on était plutôt sur un management voilà
assez autocratique avec une vision très
assertive et le fait de poser des
questions ou de demander conseil était
vu comme un signe de manque de vision de
fragilité je pense que tout ça quand
même beaucoup évolué et les jeunes
générations le monde que ce soit les
femmes que ce soit les hommes c'est pas
facile la vie de femmes chefs
d'entreprise faut trouver ou 10e
directement le bon équilibre entre la
vie de famille la vie professionnelle
entre jongler entre le bureau à la
maison ça reste plus difficile quand on
est une femme quand on est un homme
alors c'est quand même en effet la
grande question et je pense que c'est
c'est une des raisons importantes et
juste pour lesquelles en effet les
femmes se projettent pas dans les postes
à haute responsabilité
alors on va pas se mentir est-ce que
c'est beaucoup de travail oui est ce que
ça prend énormément d'énergie absolument
est ce que c'est le double de la charge
mon talent habituel et ben en fait je
pense que c'est là où je crois la
différence se fait c'est que par exemple
moi j'ai plein de choses dans ma tête
tout le temps mais je n'appelle pas ça
une charge et pour moi c'est très
important la perception et
l'interprétation que l'on fait des
choses fait toute la différence je crois
que véritablement ça doit rester un
choix positif doit pas être vécue comme
une contrainte donc on se met à parler
de charge mentale alors du coup on est
en train de subir et du coup ça devient
pénible moi j'ai l'habitude de jongler
avec plein de choses il est plein de
choses dans ma tête c'est le choix que
je fais c'est mon rythme et ça me va
bien et tant que c'est un choix positif
du coup je le vis très bien je pense que
sa part déjà de la question j'ai vu ce
chiffre là du par remettre ou à mener
qu'outil par terre comme quoi les
entreprises dirigées par des femmes
afficherait une meilleure rentabilité
32% de plus
une réaction
alors pour moi je pense qu'il ya quand
même en effet alors c'est difficile de
trouver des raisons comme ça mais je
pense que ce côté un peu je suis à
l'écouté je suis en concertation permet
aux femmes d'avoir une compréhension
assez intime de l'organisation moi je
passe ma vie à poser des questions à mes
collaborateurs je crois que ça me permet
de bien comprendre l'organisation et
donc pour arriver à sortir le meilleur
l'organisation est optimisé notamment
les modes opérateurs on sait que pleins
d'idées vient du terrain moi j'adore
passer du temps en magasin donner la
voix aux collaborateurs c'est déjà le
début la solution on parlait des freins
qui pénalise les femmes jeudi walbaum
est ce que vous avez été ou pas
d'ailleurs victime de misogynie de
machisme et voilà est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que j'ai vécue dans votre
carrière jusqu'aux sommets - après
j'imagine aux sommes évidemment non j'ai
eu la chance de pas de bas me sentir
victime de seulement deux choses
peut-être la seule chose que je peux
dire il pourrait s'assimiler à cela
c'est une fois que j'étais dirigeante
c'est le côté on a peur pour moi on a
peur qu'en fait ce soit difficile on a
peur que combiné est en fait une sorte
d'instinct de protection qui n'est pas
nécessaire parce qu à nouveau si c'est
un choix positivement en fait on se
débrouille et on le veut et on souhaite
et on sait brute pour que ça marche donc
voilà pas de la misogynie j'ai toujours
senti dès des bons sentiments la
bienveillance à mon égard et parfois
plus que nécessaire bon là merci pour ce
témoignage julie labeaume n'ont
peut-être général de maison du monde
merci merci beaucoup et s'il ya bien
deux mains
[Musique]